It is time for Hatriot Mail.
This week is a very special hatriot mail.
But first, just a reminder.
What is hatriot mail anyway?
Who needs Dr. Fauci or the CDC?
We get all the medical advice we need from
our second cousins husband's best friend's
boss on Facebook page at mail written by patriots
who hate David Pakman because of America and
because freedom.
OK, so there is something very special about
this week's Hatriot Mail, and it is part of
something I want to compile for you between
now and January 20th.
Let's take a listen and then I'll explain.
David, we know you're a loser and a disgrace,
but it doesn't matter.
And I'm not sure how helpful publishing your
videos is.
David Pakman has one of the most punchable
faces I've ever seen.
What a condescending in his mind, loser.
Don't worry, David, you'll have four more
years on talking.
Donald Trump being a loser is your best quality.
Yeah, I want to compile all of the people
still telling me we are going to get another
four years of Trump.
Joe Biden is not going to be sworn in on January
20th because I'm still getting these emails
and comments and tweets and Reddit posts and
all of it.
And, you know, at first I naively was thinking,
you know, and Joe Biden is sworn in.
These people are all going to come to a big
realization.
They're going to finally realize they were
wrong.
No, they won't.
They'll just say it was rigged.
And Biden is an illegitimate president.
They're never going to say, you know what,
I guess we were just wrong.
We were wrong.
When we said when I said Trump would overturn
it, I was simply wrong.
No, they'll say, well, it should have been
overturned, but it was rigged and Biden stole
it and blah, blah, blah.
They will never concede or accept that they
were simply wrong.
The best way to fight patriotism continues
to be to use the coupon code hatriot 40 HKT,
our Iot for zero.
When you get a membership at join Pakman Dotcom,
you save and the hatred's cry every time that
that happens